yeah Susan hello and welcome to this
video plane locomotion national master
okay and I'm cessful koffsky okay um
what can i play here I can't just go
into something male Eilish he goes with
the crew indian okay okay okay
please life's invest time in the opening
it feels
Wow what's the deal yeah yeah not just
take the center good should be two b-52
we should be 43 m blend of stuff ready
Wow
okay it looks extremely questionable
let's see how to play that
yeah just eat wit probably stroll
we need a bit early to I mean what does
define okay i od five I mean I have to
speed up a little bit I mean this is
probably not great what he played but if
you let the clock tick down you more
means he wants to play night is six and
stuff okay Letty falta at five is
something that definitely would help we
had g3n I don't think he can take this
it would be would be a quite quite risky
I thought you have to play 85 first it's
okay we'll see what happens let's see
five
now I don't know if I really refuted
this yeah it doesn't look doesn't look
like a completely refuted it a 4 B 4
might be three I might totally playable
for black never do you have to do that
now if he lets me play would be one then
Wow I don't want to think about that too
much that blacks position totally sucks
he needs to get okay okay so okay I
cannot easily play this now this before
maybe after Queen d2 though either north
or 27 is hi Alexa the idea ok I can go F
for here in this position trying to
directly crush him set an idea not
complete it bad but time wise that could
be it could be a problem let's let's
play something Queenie 7 is probably
coming attacking a 3 not completely
happy with this move but didn't see
anything greatest friends before so or
more or less have to click when you sell
but i already said an area we already
had a couple of occasions where i said
he has to play something and then he
didn't fly for this disconnection okay
that's bad yeah do I keep this game or
not probably I keep it right there are
some interesting movements at least some
a bit of an incomplete game of course
but yeah I was a bit surprised 94 looks
very time consuming yeah he formed
normal um it is it a strange ball and
okay but this this I felt sorry it
doesn't work you to g3 blunders the
bishop so we played here 93 and to h5
yeah yeah that's really tempting are you
have many many interesting move the
engine life a 38 significance which that
on likes a380 angling for before yeah
sure I mean why does clearly matter
anyway and this is just a fad center for
nothing okay d5 killing the bishop on b7
at least if I've didn't expect that move
you know k and so this was interesting I
was thinking it cannot take that this is
two way too risky 95 where's he going
the other move the left cells was
interesting was night h4 am Bishop him
and the computer like this as well as
too risky so not a 69 h4 and maybe I
could improve now a 395 we had before
yeah you know I thought about this pawn
sec but I didn't see something right
here the computer just says Quincy tool
that makes lots of sense as 93 years now
out of the picture and here threatening
quite big am NOT that's very nice for y
now I didn't didn't see De Quincey tool
I thought about before this and now I
thought like a five be three he has to
go a phone now as the engine points out
and then this position interesting that
the engine wants to sacrifice her who I
am and I actually thought about this
world but I wasn't sure if it's enough
but it's certainly some compensation but
maybe not enough when both his bishops
are quite bad but the normal thing would
have been to play here and hope for that
and if he takes I mean still sc5 not fun
so g6 would be 196 that was good and I
somehow didn't find a good move him
Queen d2 was kind of mad what what I
didn't see what what to do and now
Queenie seven looks normal but then the
knee disconnected yeah this looks like a
normal move I'm not sure what I would
have done probably really achren 80 so
I've given up some of my advantage by
not playing before something that I
missed here before very strong the lane
move f3 got black back into the game and
by a five he can locate the queenside
quite reliably yeah ok guys thanks for
watching
[Music]